the race between infections and
injections is a shuffle not a sprint
led by the over 80s including the man
behind housewife superstar
dame edna everage i'm an out of work
actor
and i've had to give the performance of
a lifetime pretending to be old enough
to get the vaccine
the uk's arsenal has been bolstered by
the approval of a third vaccine
produced by moderna it won't be
available for patients until the spring
but ministers are confident they have
enough of the pfizer and astrazeneca
to hit two million doses a week soon
we've got
literally between now and and and
february uh
many millions of both vaccines coming
through
i now have a much clearer line of sight
for those deliveries and therefore i can
tell you that the nhs plan
i can tell you that it's challenging and
stretching but i'm confident we can meet
from monday ashton gate in bristol will
be part of that effort
the stadium closed to fans but open to
thousands of patients
after armed forces personnel turned the
south stand concourse
into a field hospital it's fully
compatibilized it's been turned sterile
and clinical if you like
the concessions which would usually be
pumping out hundreds of thousands of
pies and points are now a number of
pharmacies
um it's yeah it's we're very much
looking forward to hosting it and be
able to support the nhs and uh not just
in bristol but nationally
after months of mass testing for
coronavirus a more hopeful project
is underway if vaccines are going to
catch up with the virus then places like
this
will be crucial working seven days a
week they hope to deliver
a thousand doses a day to people from
across the south
west but ultimately this victory won't
be won here
but in hundreds of gp surgeries and
health centers
across the country ashton gate is one of
seven mass vaccination centers in stadia
and conference
centers across the country by the end of
next week 223 hospital hubs in england
will be vaccinating nhs staff and
patients
but the majority of doses will be
administered locally by gps and
pharmacists operating from more than one
thousand locations
by the end of next week ensuring
supplies reach every part of the network
is key
and it's been a patchy start but at the
green bank medical practice in oldham
is so far so good i think it's been very
positive there has been uh teething
issues and we had a week to set up so
there were some blips that we
endured in uh just before christmas but
we've been able to smooth out those
issues
there's better it systems on board now
and there's an appointment booking
system to vaccinate almost a quarter of
the population in
six weeks every part of the system will
need to work
lives and the return of normal life
depend on it
paul kelso sky news in bristol